so this girl this girl that went on
rogan so many people are like dude yeah
listen this girl's story on north korea
how kids were you dying i know her she
escaped better apparently she's
now hold on before i say the story i
don't know anything about this woman i
didn't listen to the podcast i've seen
all the headlines all that stuff
apparently from other friends that i
have go she's kind of like she wants to
be like the kim kardashian of north
korea like she's just doing it for
exposure she's made all of this up
because i i
talked with her and i have her number in
my phone
because i was going to go do a thing in
new york sure apparently she's full of
[ __ ] and i also had seen her see and
then this is tim dillon our good friend
of mine goes i heard this trick who's
making the pockets rounds as a fraud and
she was the kim kardashian of north
korea korea he was like continue to
support norway now does he know that
because that's a hard thing to say hold
on bubba it's
damn it one thing about tim i don't
think he would have tim's not a
bullshitter that's one thing tim's not
great comic
fantastic friend not a bullshitter yeah
i i uh i have i will keep my opinion to
myself because i had i had an
interesting
feeling when i was speaking to this
person for the hour that i spent spoke
to her by interesting feeling do you
being called [ __ ] and you know
[ __ ] or brian yeah again i don't i
know nothing about this woman i didn't
see the podcast so i don't know but i
saw this and i was like because so many
people were like dude everyone was ready
they're like you should hear a story
yeah how bad north korea is and stuff
like that like jesus is a crazy story i
don't know man her story was very
powerful when i listened to it on ted on
a ted talk so um
she's been around for a minute but i
have i had without going into details
there were things about her that i found
to be uh
interesting
interesting
yeah that's interesting right so what
what do we do no this is the this first
anybody's in here has heard of this you
you never heard of you've never heard of
it i just saw her popping up on youtube
a lot all over yeah yeah
and then and then i read something on
barstool who's like yeah i hear this
crazy story so i clicked on the i
clicked on the clip and it was
so tragic i was like i don't want it
yeah they're like yo this whole podcast
i'm like i'm all set right i got it
right i'm all set right and i saw it
popping up other places and then i was
talking to a good buddy about he's like
yeah dude have you seen uh apparently
she's a fraud she makes a lot of this up
i'm like no way
and then i saw then someone sent me that
was like yeah even tim dillon's calling
it i'm like oh [ __ ]
again i don't know it could be all true
how i'm not trying to start a rumor no i
don't know but i'm just saying it's well
um somebody else in here knew
interesting because when when [ __ ] like
this happens
uh
okay
when [ __ ] like this happens it's it's
interesting because there's a lot a lot
of times there probably is some truth
too scroll down absolutely not she's
been caught lying about so many things
that everything she says is suspect
journalists have lost their careers for
lies she's making more money saying
shocking things than experts and even
though the factors are on it's uh she
claimed to cross the gobi desert in four
degrees low weather without any winter
clothing and justify the claims
outrageous by appealing to miracles huh
i don't know man i i maybe maybe this is
a north korean
uh
psyop to discredit that's what they do
that is what they do so that could also
be the case so we have to be careful i i
when i heard her story and and i i found
it very credible
um and it's it's and if it's not true i
guarantee that that story happens all
the time in north korea when you try to
get out of there you know so maybe
it's a horrible place maybe no no north
korea is the worst place awful yeah yeah
awful so i think that story exists
whether or not it happens
i i don't know uh here's what i don't
know here's what i'll say
i don't know i don't know i thought this
was interesting to talk about i i don't
i can't i couldn't tell her name all i
know is i've had a bunch of people that
i know and trust go dude i think she
might be fuller so here's what i'm going
to say i guess i can say this i'm going
to slap your face you can trap
things up dude tell the [ __ ] story if
i'm here where are you gonna go right
yeah
i'm gonna slap you and your lying friend
i'm gonna slap you back okay you don't
know who's fully if she's a liar yet no
i have no idea i i
but i'm a betting man
yeah if i have to bet
you know i don't know
when dylan tweets it out
and i know he probably does his he does
his [ __ ] deep dives and [ __ ] like
that that's what he does you know that's
just what he does but he's a kid and i
don't think he would put it out there
true but also i don't think he put
something out there has he tweeted any
more chin about it
is it a north korean psyop they're they
have they have their own [ __ ] oh yeah
they got to infiltrate the media and
stuff like that does she does she live
in the states now or something yeah yeah
i can see the north koreans doing this
to her
so before i say anything i don't want to
i don't want to condemn her yeah yeah i
don't know enough about it yeah
yeah
did tim hear this from a reliable source
because tim's pretty fair what was it
oh there it is
okay so i'm just going to say this i'm
going to say this click on that but say
but
the way she's dressed is very considered
and theatrical okay this one i saw too
that says 2014.
yeah
2014 is deliberate and considered
like there is the thing keep scrolling
down
celebrity defector
park is one of the stars of a television
program featuring cast of north korean
women's called now on my way to meet you
uh
okay
like here's the thing uh she's known as
the paris hilton north korea
in one episode early in 2013 she appears
with her mother family photographs flash
on screen parks jokes that's my mom
there she's beautiful for right uh to be
honest i'm not piercing my mom is the
real piercing okay
yeah oh do you guys know this website or
although i don't know i don't know i
read a lot of this it was called the
diplomat yeah yeah i don't know it's
from 2014 so i don't know either yeah
yeah i don't know who knows it's
interesting to talk about now yeah
um
in a way i don't mind that she's
bringing she's highlighting it she's
highlighting what a [ __ ] horrible
regime it is and i don't mind that like
and if she did come from north korea if
that's true
that in a way i guarantee things weren't
easy no right but she crossed that
arctic desert with no clothes on that's
a question how did she get spun up the
lies a little bit yeah how did she get
across though did she lose her sister
did her father was her father in a work
camp that's all possible yeah you know
um but
she
she's very she is very beautiful yeah
she's very beautiful
i believe she's had
stuff going on yeah that would be common
common in that culture right yeah south
korea for sure
very very she's very yeah very doll like
you know kind of
there's yeah
i thought that was interesting i was
like
you know
but i don't know
english is great
she's
she's
she seemed very kind
very kind
so i don't know yeah i never heard about
her until uh everyone kept posting me
from her being on rogan yeah i think
we're gonna find out yeah but the
question oh yeah they'll dive into it
yeah but the question is does it matter
right if she came from north korea i
think it does we don't well if she came
from north korea we
we don't know how do we find out that
she you know yeah if her dad was in a
work camp which he probably was and then
died of cancer if her sister was killed
by a border guard you know i don't
really care to be honest yeah like if
she lies or not it's not the end of the
world that she's
yeah it's not the end of the world she
might have added a little spice to her
story
it is interesting if you came from north
korea already i'm going to go through
your life sucks because she's really
small too and like my friend my friend
was doing security for the olympics he
said i'm not afraid of the north koreans
anymore i said why he goes they're so
tiny
their lack of nutrition is so crazy even
among their best athletes that they're
tiny they look tiny so she's tiny she's
like so tinder a rarity
i mean
no i mean chin's americans shaquille
o'neal koreans are you'll see some thick
strongest buck koreans i was actually
born in korea though so i'm i am more
rare i would say yeah yeah
are you your folks are tall yeah thick
though
yeah here there's a bunch of huge queens
like i have two friends that are here
they're not right in korea they're not
naturally i was the biggest one when i
visited korea but they're always like
the koreans are pretty thick actually
yeah don't you think yeah i mean i had i
was like
first judo the really the power lifters